-Hi, Jim.
-Hi, Jimmy.
How are you?
-You look great.
-You look really good too.
I like this casual thing
you have going.
-Oh, thank you.
-You're welcome.
-I always love seeing you and we
always talk about New York City,
because I know
you're back in the city.
-Yeah.
-And I want to say
I heard this before,
right before the interview,
but I didn't know
that you had COVID at one point.
-Well, not everybody did.
But I figure, you know,
why not talk about it
with you on television?
-Wow.
-Yeah.
We had it.
Todd and I both had it early on.
It was like middle of March.
And we didn't know what --
I'm sorry.
I'm putting the dog down.
We didn't know what it was.
We thought we had colds.
And, then, it seemed less
likely, and then, finally,
we lost our sense of smell
and taste and we were like --
-You did?
-Yeah. Utterly.
And it defied the descriptions
for me.
I didn't realize how completely
taste and smell could be gone.
And when you're in quarantine,
and there is really nothing
to do but eat,
oh, my God.
That was brutal.
-So, you didn't feel like
eating anything
or just like everything
was just gross?
-Oh, no, I ate everything,
but I just didn't taste it.
You know?
It was the definition
of wasted calories.
-Right, yeah.
I'm so happy that you guys
are back to being healthy.
-Yeah, me too.
-How did you stay busy
once you felt better?
-Well, I tried
other creative outlets
because acting obviously
wasn't happening,
and I took a painting class
for a while.
I took a creative writing class
And everything petered out.
I don't know if the truth is,
"Well, you're just an actor,
and that's what you do
and that's what you should do,"
or if it's just I really
don't have the see-through
stick-to-it-ness for anything.
It's sort of embarrassing,
but, you know, here I am.
-Everyone went through phases.
I know you went through
a blond phase in quarantine.
Look at this. Wow.
-I did.
-I like it. What made you want
to bleach your hair?
-Well, I had dealt
with bleached products --
Who says bleached products?
I had bleached my hair,
like a bottle job and stuff
off and on in my 20s,
and it had been so long
since I'd done it,
for obvious reasons --
work and the show --
and I kept thinking,
"I'm going to do it now
that the show is over,
but I'm going to do it right.
I'm going to have somebody do it
where it looks
natural and whatever."
And then quarantine hit,
and I thought, "Well, I guess
I'm not doing it."
And then about six weeks in
and we'd been sick,
I was like, "Screw it.
Let's buy some crap."
And Todd did it.
-Yeah.
-It took about six hours.
It burned my scalp.
But you know what?
Beauty is pain.
Or a mediocre look.
-There is that one minute,
right, where you go,
"Am I going to fry
all my hair off?
What's happening?"
-Yes.
-"Let's wash it out
because it's not working.
Something's happening."
-You know this feeling
very well, obviously.
-Unfortunately, I think
we have it in the control room.
That's me.
-Oh, Jimmy, yes!
Wait. What is this for?
-This was for a movie
called "Factory Girl."
-I remember seeing you
like this. Absolutely right.
-I was in the neighborhood.
It was so --
And at the time, I thought --
You can take it off the screen
now. It's just terrible.
They kind of left it up
a little bit too long there.
-Hold it. Hold it.
-Someone up there is like,
"Yeah, I'll get him."
I thought like,
"Oh, I can do the blo--"
My character had blond hair.
I go, "I can do that."
And it just came out
completely orange and it was --
-I don't think
it looks that bad.
I say it because it doesn't look
that different from mine.
So, looks pretty good.
[ Laughter ]
-I like the way it is now.
It kind of looks much
more professional.
-Yeah, they "fixed" it.
-Ah.
-I now have a wonderful colorist
here in New York,
which I never needed before,
but I threw on a mask
and was like, "I need help.
Please." Oh, God.
-I remember when we were talking
when you were on the show
and we showed a photo of you
when you first got
to New York City,
and I think you were
blond then as well.
Yeah. That's it.
-See? I told you.
My 20s were a time of bleached
hair and sleeping on couches.
Yes, that was my first trip
to New York.
-Look at you, Times Square.
-That is Times Square, isn't it?
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
-I know, I know.
I'm sorry.
Take that photo off, too.
Please.
Making us reminisce too much.
My gosh.
I haven't seen you since
"The Big Bang Theory" ended.
-Yeah.
-It was the first time for you,
probably, in a long time
that you weren't doing it.
Was it weird?
-Yeah, it was weird.
It's been really hard to decide
what is "Big Bang" being gone
and what's being now stuck in
this weird time of quarantine,
like, the whole world
is in this weird time.
But, yeah, the weirdest part
for me was the way --
and I'm sorry
this sounds morbid --
but it reminds me of when
someone dies or a pet passes
and it feels so monumental
in the moment and you think,
"Well, this will never end."
And then one day
you kind of look up
and you're like,
"Oh, nine months have gone by.
Okay. I guess life carries on."
I mean, not that it wasn't --
it wasn't --
I mean, it was bittersweet
when it ended, but it was fine.
-Yeah.
A lot of people were talking
on the Internet
of how they think Sheldon
would handle the pandemic.
What do you think he'd be doing?
-He was built for this.
I mean, this is the moment
he was waiting for.
I was saying earlier we had
an entire episode,
which I didn't think about
until recently,
where he did like a Shell-bot
where he had a video screen
on a remote control
wheelie thing.
That was when people
still needed
to get together in groups.
And so he would just send that
out and sit in his room.
-Yeah, he didn't
have to see humans, yeah.
-Yeah. Don't touch me.
Don't sneeze on me.
So I guess he'd be fine.
-You've been doing a lot
of great things since then.
You were nominated for an Emmy
this year for "Hollywood."
Congrats on that.
That was great, by the way.
I loved "Hollywood."
-Thank you.
-How was the virtual
Emmy experience?
What was that like?
-So bizarre.
-It's weird, right?
-So, you didn't
have to wear a tux,
but I had a tux,
and I was like, "Why not?"
So, me and Todd put on our tuxes
and got ready,
and then we just walked
to the living room.
And it was like,
this feels really odd.
And then the whole thing,
I think the strangest part
for me
was right before the category
was announced that I was up for,
they threw all the nominees
into a virtual waiting room,
where they were like you
and I are right now on Zoom,
and we could all kind of chat,
which I was like,
"I don't -- We're all up
for the same award.
This is weird."
But it ended up not being weird.
It was actually very
humanizing and sweet.
Then Yahya won, and it was like
somebody in the group had won.
It was kind of really happy.
But he finished his speech,
and we all applaud,
and then suddenly,
literally from the Emmys,
to leave it, you just go "leave
meeting" and then you were done.
I was like --
-What? Wow.
-It was on Zoom.
It was so bizarre.
-That is really --
-Kind of nice.
I could eat and drink during it.
-Yeah, that's true.
At commercial break,
you could actually walk
around your house
and do whatever.
-Yeah.
-I think it's kind of fun, too,
having a conversation
with your fellow actors
who you're "up against."
-Well, it really gave
the lie to --
We're not playing sports here.
Nobody is beating anybody
at anything.
We're all just doing our work,
and if you happen
to get an award, great.
But it's like, there's not
really a competition here.
It's just a nice moment
of recognition.
-We're actually all on
the same team, weirdly.
-That's exactly right.
-You're in another
Ryan Murphy film,
"The Boys in the Band."
I want to talk about this.
We talked about the play
last time you were on,
but you're getting
great reviews for this.
Do you mind if you stick around?
I'll talk about that?
-I need to go to the bathroom,
but maybe. Okay, yes, I'll stay.
-More with Jim Parsons
after the break, everybody.